and Beth strikes did come up in in prime
minister's questions but what Kirsten
will really pushed the Prime Minister on
was uh funding for private schools the
amount of money that could be generated
if vat was removed from them and of
course targeting Winchester which is the
school that the Prime Minister himself
went to I mean it's curious in a way
Jane in that that he went on that in
that what what's the issue for people on
people's minds at the moment it will be
cost of living and Strikes but what
kirstmer did there is I think develop an
attack line that we are going to see
again and again and they've only gone up
against each other a few times but you
can see what's happening here Kia stalma
raised a policy issue this is VAT on
private school fees now labor have said
that they will in State uh put VAT on
fees if they win the election a clear
policy division between the
conservatives and the labor party uh
labor think it would raise about 1.7
billion but why did care starmer or the
manner in which he did that was both in
a personal attack on the prime minister
in an attempt to sort of frame Rishi
sanak again as someone that he argues is
weak I know it's being pushed around by
what labor call invested interests and
in this case uh being pushed around or
giving money unnecessarily in his view
to those private schools but he used it
in a way to remind us all the Rishi
sunak went to a very very prestigious
Public School Winchester College because
he used it as tax breaks worth six
million that was the point kirstan was
making to Winchester college and he is
trying to frame the Prime Minister as
someone who protects vested interests
instead of standing up to working people
but making it a personal attack as well
of his own privilege and they have done
this in different ways raising the issue
of non-dom status you remember Rishi
sunak's wife was a non bomb she has
since changed her tax status and last
week people not care starmer himself but
labor politicians raising the issue of
whether or not Rishi sunak has Private
health care so framing him if you like
as a person of privilege who is out of
touch but also trying to find these
dividing lines between labor and the
conservatives be it on the windfall tax
labor talking about how they would have
introduced her earlier how much that
would have raised or public schools now
actually to be fair to Rishi sooner he
had a good rebuttal on that in that he
said my parents worked very hard to pay
those fees his mother a pharmacist his
father a GP to pay those schools to fees
to one of the best public schools in the
country and he accused kirstma of
attacking aspiration attacking people's
aspirations the second line of attack
was why don't you get tough with your
back benches on house building and he
had the rebuttal again Rishi sunak of
well why don't you kirst armor get tough
on labor MPS joining the picket lines
but you can see now the Contours of
where Kirsten clearly thinks he can
attack Rishi Suna corn one is on
privilege and the second is on what he
perceives as uh Rishi sunak's weakness
these are two clear lines of attack that
the labor leader is now developing